put the lotion in the basket I get to I
psychobabble and now we're here we're
here it happened I like pass out like
you in shy can you hear me uh yeah kind
of bitumen against a sheep are oh you
are good but that might be the end of
you unfortunately your friends also
found their way here not unconscious
just like you wondering what happened
you were hit by casino security detects
anything for radio app it subdues 12
visiting moves if needed getting into
perish all recordings the guests who
were trapped here shut that noise off
looks like the casino move your friends
around once inside might be useful what
do they came to help or kill you still
my signal should work through the
speakers now that you're inside well
welcome to the sierra madre in all its
glory mm-hmm this is what the old world
stood for filled with bombs about to
rain down on him now look at it
beautiful now his guests are all dead
better this way quiet how the Mavi
should be now with a ksiva was sleeping
it's got places closed off won't let you
go yet he'll get there just being
attached me to wake it up
figure that I don't know it's gonna it
is the past you're walking through if
you have ever seen no one else ever will
I work hard to get here it'll give me
what I need before I leave and always
not look for a way to wake this goes
Kozma reminder it's got guests [ __ ]
scary
but I wish I did just like a weight or
something shut
oh great what the [ __ ] I suppose they
doing Isaac I yellow oh great
I'll go I'll go upstairs then all right
that make sense it does makes a lot of
sense but [ __ ] [ __ ] hate this [ __ ] so
knowing okay where it is a speaker I
just like [ __ ] it oh there we go
[ __ ] oh no thanks Pierre I will I get a
cigarette cigarette cigarette cigarette
so everyone loves those cigarettes you
know even a video game that just feel
myself drawn to shut shut and it's a
good [ __ ] here ok
still annoying because I feel like I
have to save over two seconds because
I'm like any of these [ __ ] like
beeping things at killing oh [ __ ] what's
are there ashtrays no thank you not a
smoker how start no thank you
dogs in there he says where the [ __ ] is
a speaker
where the [ __ ] is a speaker yeah yeah
yeah ojala gain control Jesus
come on uh you like tries to punish you
okay wait that X on the exact match that
1000 off turn off
you
it's in here I said where the [ __ ] is
that [ __ ] is this count oh [ __ ] this
counts [ __ ] but I got that I got low
popular that scares the [ __ ] out of it
every time [ __ ] it sucks dick Hall
alright so good Oh
ok that worked how does it feel crippled
looms okay did it okay for a second I
thought I'd like want to do yes I'll
take this thank you very much thank you
very much what is it light bulbs and
shat said two modules and shat Oh
anything it is yet ok so let's cape gun
let's keep God
they should all be at the bar now right
where the [ __ ] is it
okay okay theater what what's my
objective find a way to turn on the
power right or get everything back up
gain access de hecho closet so it's
gonna be like it knows here that I'd
like almost [ __ ] locked oh it's good
that blocked ok what's probably in the
sweet son right
it says to go to the electro closet with
the [ __ ] you had my something I wasn't
exactly really take them to the ship oh
yeah I did okay let's go let's go
there we go
m ok
okay get a get in there
[ __ ] look in their own way um can I
change where he's going oh I don't know
he's [ __ ] run after me
not ravioli ravioli give me Yoli shet
shet the dark